hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be all the rest of my daredevil videos
it'll be episode seven through the
finale so just careful for spoilers if
you have not seen daredevil season two
yet really starting with the trial of
the Punisher which is kind of what picks
up in Episode seven through the rest of
the series it's all about Elektra in the
hand they basically set the Punisher up
and now the task is we begin some of the
heavy mythology like what's going on
with black sky the mystery behind that
as well as reintroducing the kingpin
character so happy that he's back it's
not a season of daredevil without the
kingpin there are definitely some really
big moments throughout you can feel
where they're ceding stories for
daredevil seasons 3 going forward like
the kingpin for instance comes roaring
back to life in the narrative like the
minute I get out of here I am coming to
hunt you down I'm going to destroy you
that is comic book kingpin right there
the way he manipulates the situation so
that when he does walk out of jail the
city will just be sitting there for him
to take he does the clever thing of
unleashing the Punisher on his
competition killing two birds with one
stone
daredevil finally gets his retractable
billy club from the comics which is
badass and we got to talk a lot about
Elektra I know a lot of you were
confused about the whole black sky twist
in the comics both daredevil and Electra
have been a part of the hand as well as
a part of the chase they jump back and
forth at various points depending on
which storyline you're in the funniest
thing I've heard about season 2 so far
is that people are worried because of
all this black sky electric stuff that
the defenders team-up series is building
towards a Shadowland storyline and
people were really horrified by the idea
that because Shadowland wasn't that
great of a story in the comics which is
to explain that comic book e-string
because they kind of weave that in with
the Elektra storyline the black sky
black sky equals the Beast of the comics
the beast that the hand worships where
they gain their power and their mastery
over death
imagine the hand raising a demon using
electro that's kind of what's going on
they're gonna resurrect her and she will
be fully possessed she'll be the evil
Elektra that you may have seen from the
comics but also in the comics during the
Shadowlands series they suspected the
daredevil himself had been possessed by
the Beast because he starts killing
people he starts doing things more like
the Punisher it remains to be seen but
Elektra Wilkin
you to be a big force in the daredevil
universe there's there's no way that
she's gonna stay dead a lot of people
were disappointed that she didn't get
killed by bullseye which is how she dies
the first time in the comics but she
does end up coming back so as much as
they change from the comics they are
still doing a lot of comic-book things
Easter eggs though I think I've already
talked a little bit about the trial of
the Punisher he is on trial Marc
Guggenheim who is the showrunner for
arrow and also writes a lot of Marvel
comics including Punisher comics one of
those was a storyline called the trial
of the Punisher several characters keep
repeating the phrase war zone it's a war
zone out there just a reference to
Punisher war zone in the comic book
title Punisher going to jail is a nice
reference to punish her max where he
actually gets locked up in prison
stick starts to explain the chase and
even though the way he explains it on
the TV show is different from the way
it's presented in the comic books they
were first introduced in daredevil 187
it was a Frank Miller invention and it's
much more ancient than what stick makes
out he makes it sound like he's also
mastered death like he's this ancient
person it's really meant to be kind of
ambiguous so you could choose to believe
that stick really is the chaste person
like the original creator of the chaste
order but that's just daredevil wading
into mysticism which I think it will
really double down on during Iron Fist
once we get to that series you'll really
see magic in the TV universe or at least
as close as we'll get to magic
when Karen pages at the newspaper a lot
of the headlines you will see refer to
other things that have happened in the
Marvel Universe like the Battle of New
York there's a headline that says
cybertek settles that's the company on
agents of shield that built Dedlock we
get to see Madame Gao again who's gonna
be a huge thing during the Iron Fist
series if you're not really familiar
with Iron Fist characters the one that
she seems like is crane mother who's
kind of attached to this evil version of
iron fist
the villains of iron fist we can talk
about a little bit more when we get
closer to that series Punisher finally
gets his comic book costume after he
takes down the blacksmith who winds up
being his old military commander if you
were confused about what happened with
Punishers family and how the blacksmith
was responsible for it he just took over
the drug trade by having all these gangs
take down each other and Punishers
family was collateral damage
the blacksmith did not kill his family
on purpose they
just in the wrong place at the wrong
time more Jessica Jones Easter eggs
jeryn hogarth shows up to offer foggy a
job which he accepts so now we're
definitely connected to the Jessica
Jones series if we weren't before and a
lot of you have asked me about the drive
that the punisher pulled out of his
house before he blew it up think of that
the way you would think of the list on
arrow just information on people doing
really bad things that Punisher is going
to go after because they're connecting
all these series remember during Jessica
Jones the Stars and Stripes character
would take those pills there was a
secret company that was using them
testing them on military personnel don't
be surprised if Punisher starts to
intersect with those types of characters
because they came out of the military
Punishers a military person so by the
time we get to defenders all these like
big shadow organizations will start to
make a little more sense there's that
other company that gave Jessica Jones
and kilgrave their powers they'll
probably get involved but the stars of
daredevil jet you know just the
daredevil actors have talked about
things that they would like to do in
seasons three and four which include
bullseye more comic book characters so
daredevil just by itself will probably
continue I wouldn't be surprised that
they get a full five seasons maybe
beyond that a lot of that will just
depend on how long the actors want to
keep doing it but the other last big
easter egg you know actually they tease
that they're gonna be bringing Elektra
back from the dead or at least more
fully possessed by the Beast is the Luke
Cage trailer Luke Cage is dropping
September thirtieth so it's actually
coming pretty soon I've already done a
video on that so I'll put a link for it
in the description but let me know what
did you guys think of daredevil season 2
overall it was a great series they did
try to cram in that romance with Karen
page just to create some tension when
Elektra came along so there were like a
few unnecessary things that they jammed
in
but Punisher was amazing can't wait to
see more of him he definitely needs his
own spin-off series hand vs chase was
pretty intriguing stick totally loved
the way he took down Nobu at the end
stay down this time and I know a
lot of you have asked about Jessica
Jones season 2 they haven't started
shooting that yet but they have started
writing it so it will happen but we
probably won't see it till next year
there is new legends of tomorrow tonight
there's a bunch of Jonah Hex stuff so
I'll try to address that when I post
that video later while you guys wait for
that you can click here for that Luke
Cage trailer and you can click here for
the last Civil War trailer
just posted thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you